الموسيقى التصويريه هذا العالم السحري
الذي نعيشه من خلاله احداث المشهد من
يضعها وما تفاصيل هذه المهنه نتعرف عليها
مع الموسيقار خالد القمار
خالد القمار اهلا بك ثلاث مسلسلات السنه
دي في رمضان الهرش السبعه الصندوق والازهر
كلمني كده عن التجربه والاختلاف قدرت
تعمله ازاي وملحيات التلاته غير بعض تماما
يعني اللي هو ما كنتش اتخيل انه ممكن في
يوم من الايام بشتغل على ثلاث مشاريع
مختلفين هذا الاختلاف يعني وهذا التنوع
مختلفين اولا من ناحيه النوع اللي بيقدموه
ان هو واحد اجتماعي واحد الدراما شعبيه
مخلوطه باكشن وانتقام وما الى ذلك واحد
تاني
وكده
ده من ناحيه من الناحيه التانيه ان هم
كمان كل واحد منهم بيخاطب فئه مختلفه
تماما يعني سواء فيها عمريه او اجتماعيه
يعني
[موسيقى]
فهو انا الاول بكتب الموسيقى كلها على
الكمبيوتر هي على قد ما بتبدو وبسيطه على
قد ما احنا كل سطر من دول الاله مختلفه
ايه الالات اتسجلت في لندن
الكمنجات والحاجات دي
بكتب النواه كلها وبعتها لهم وبتتسجل هناك
الموسيقى التصويريه بتاعه اي عمل دي قرار
منفرد للموسيقي او شغل منفرد للموسيكل ولا
بيبقى بينه وما بين المخرج عشان نوصل نفس
الرؤيه انا بالنسبه لي الهدف الاساسي
المؤلف في الموسيقى التصويريه هو ان هو
يعمل الموسيقى اللي تقدر تكمل العمل باحسن
شكل ممكن فهي عشان تقدر تكمل العمل لازم
تكون في الاخر بتوجيه المخرج او برؤيه
المخرج لان هو اكثر حد شايف العمل على
بعضه هيبقى عامل ازاي في الاخر بس اذكر من
ده مثلا فيلم
صاحب المقاومه مثلا لما قريته تخيلته فيلم
مظلم عن اللي حصل يعني يعني عشان كده
هتلاقيه المزيكا عملتها في الاول كانت
مزيكا غامقه شويتين وبعدين لما طفل لقيت
استاذ المخرج عامله بروح خفيفه كده بالعكس
روح مبهجه جدا يعني بس فساعتها حتى طبعا
ان انا اعدل المزيكا عشان تلائم رؤيته
يعني
[موسيقى]
كلمني عن الجائزه بتاعه هوليود وازاي اثرت
عليك وعلى الكارير بتاعك
[موسيقى]
اختفى 2019 او 2020
عن موسيقى مسلسل القبيل انا كانت بالنسبه
لي حاجه لا يصدقه عقلي يعني لان هي بيشارك
فيها ناس من جميع انحاء العالم يعني
[موسيقى]
احنا واحنا صغيرين كان فكره ان انا اقدر
اسمع موسيقى التصويريه منفصله في حد ذاتها
يعني عن العمل كانت نادره جدا جدا
لما المزيكا متاحه للناس اللي بتسمع اكثر
بكثير فبتدي الناس تناقش اكثر بكثير وفي
نفس الوقت برضو ده خلى ان في حاله من
التنافس الجميل يعني بين المؤلفين وبعض ان
كل واحد بقى حاسس انه
[موسيقى]
انه هيبقى يعني بيقيم بشكل ادق من زمان
يعني
[موسيقى]
هل المؤلف الموسيقى مطلوب منه انه يبقى
موسيقار فقط ولا كمان لازم يبقى فاهم او
دارس سينما او دراما انا بالنسبه لي بحس
ان هو لازم
مش شرط بمعنى دراسه بس ممكن يعني اهم حاجه
يبقى ايري كثير يبقى شخص بيقرا كتير عشان
الموسيقى التصويريه هي بتعتمد على النفس
الطويل او نقدر نقول الاوفي رو والسترك
بتاع الاحداث يعني
في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات